let me start with the Dodgers how did it
go south so quickly here Tom hey don't
forget there are only a one-nothing win
over the Padres from losing 17 in a row
maybe they'll get there anyway I don't
know you know it's almost as if that big
lead was almost too much for them they
started really playing on cruise control
you know Dave Roberts is making sure all
the starting pitchers got extra rest
bench guys were getting a lot of time
don't forget Corey Seager went down with
an injury to the elbow and that really
hurt them what I found to Dan is that
the Dodgers pitching staff which loves
to throw high fastball you know today's
game everybody wants to hit the ball in
the air so they're vulnerable to high
fastball well that's what the Dodgers
have seen in the second half of the
season and by adding Granderson giving
it back to Kiki Hernandez they got a ton
of guys who can't hit a high fastball
and that's how things are attacking that
right now I still think they're a good
shape crazy as that sounds their whole
season is about the postseason right
yeah giveme Kershaw Hill and Darvish
lined up rested ready to go and there
was good as anybody all right that
brings me to the Indians now with their
winning streak how did this come about
and the fact that their starters have
been unbelievable I guess is probably
part of the answer here absolutely you
definitely have to start with their
starting pitchers and I actually go back
to the last postseason remember when
they took down to Blue Jays and almost
took down the Cubs their pitchers threw
a ton of breaking balls and why not when
you can throw a wiffle ball the way that
Corey Kluber can throw his and they
carried that into this year they've
actually been on a cutting edge but
trying to baseball now or even though
there's more velocity in the game
pitchers are throwing more fastballs are
fewer fast balls no lied in fast balls
get hit they really do hitters have
adjusted to velocity so the Indians are
one of the few teams now that drove less
than 50% fastball so Kluber is throwing
career high curveballs Trevor Bauer
throwing a career high curveballs
Carrasco career high slider
Salazar career high changeup on and on
it goes
these guys have great stuff don't get me
wrong but they're pitching backward now
and now that was part of the pack
yeah and I you know hitters will say I
can adjust I can get to a hundred it'll
take me a little while to adjust to it
but you can eventually get there you
don't hear somebody say yeah I can
adjust to the curveball or the slider
right I mean it's no you're absolutely
right and I think as much as we were Wow
that's all of it look at every game you
see right you got guys throwing 95 and
above and it looks impressive on the
radar gun and all that but the fact is
as you said these hitters can adjust and
I think this eighth generation of
hitters have adjusted to velocity and
Indians know that and I think the
success they had in the post season well
I know this I've talked to the pitching
coach Mickey Callaway about this really
changed their thinking that old-school
mentality of eight establish your
fastball your other stuff is
complimentary big turn that upside down
and it's working and Kluber going
tonight listen I got like the Indians
chances whether winning streak or not
that guy right now is as good as anybody
in baseball Cubs are kind of hanging in
there though I know that they haven't
gotten the attention maybe that's a good
thing for them handicap the Cubs chances
at repeating yeah not good no I think
listen they they've struggled all your
day I don't think they've played with
any urgency all year long they've been
good enough and probably will be good
enough so your first place team and all
is said and done but they're just not
the same team then and schwarber you
know that team's found a hole in his
when he's just not anywhere close to
what they thought hayward hasn't really
got much better incrementally maybe than
last year they've got a lot of outs in
their lineup that being said they've
beaten up on some bad teams a lot of
them in the National League this year
but listen they're they're a notch below
both the Dodgers and the Washington
Nationals now maybe they get their act
together and the magic deep best shows
up and knocked over but they're just as
good as they were last year if you're a
Dodger fan are you nervous yeah I've got
to be nervous watching them night after
night lose games like this but again I
gonna see a different team in a
postseason I don't think Granderson and
Adrian Gonzalez going to get all these
at-bats and Keith Hernandez and tend to
my edit and in June were you are not
going to start
games in the postseason this planet
there is better work you know they
basically played the second half almost
like it's spring training not quite but
you know in terms of using their desk
but they better make sure they tighten
up at the end of the season yeah I'll go
back to all five right over the White
Sox one yeah they had a 15 game lead in
August in the last three weeks of the
season was down to one and a half it was
panic City what they finished those last
two weeks really strong I remember Paul
Konerko after they won the World Series
that listen it wasn't fun going through
it but I don't think we win the World
Series unless we had to tighten up at
the end of the year so maybe that
moments coming for the Dodgers one final
question Fritzi would like to ask you
this time is there any scenario if this
continues to go poorly for the Dodgers
and they get they bow out basically in
the first round even gets swept could
Dave Roberts his job be in jeopardy at
all in LA he is the right manager for
that team you know I always said that
anybody deserves like I'm not even
called a bad year but say one failure
one slip-up and if they don't get out of
the first round it's easy to say it's a
failure season for them the lease would
shorten certainly but no they love him
in LA any other questions 44-ton think
I'm good I appreciate that okay Tom
thank you for joining us we appreciate
it
that's Tom Verducci Sports Illustrated
senior baseball writer the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience